[Music]  [Music]  v-mon and you made it you blown up all  over the news are you alone I just want  the money you got the chip  all right start her up  why don't you go to the bathroom wash up  we gonna be with you in a minute  aha come on man your neck it's a mess  initiating combat mode  destination all right in and out [ __ ]  we're rich oh we are going to the major  leagues charity  Jake oh okay  get to clinic now it's toilets condition  critic don't you get just hold on hey  hey just think about all the good [ __ ]  we're gonna have huh oh sorry  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  take the [ __ ] shift X every corporate  cop in this city is gonna be blasting  down these doors after what you and your  psycho frontier we didn't need all this  [ __ ] attention damn it  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  wait the [ __ ] off samurai we have a city  to burn